Well, Chris, Damond,
congratulations.
You guys are moving forward
in the third and final round
of our competition.
Now, gentlemen, in
this last round,
we're going to be sending
you back to your home forges
to build one of
three iconic weapons
from our Fortune
Fire vault. We've
got the pandat, the
boa-zande, and the kelewang.
Now, gentlemen, we've got
to keep to the casino theme,
so we're going to spin the
Wheel of Forging again.
But here's the deal-- if you
don't like where you land,
you have an option to press
your luck and spin again.
But those 4 days
total the 35 hours.
If you choose to spin again,
we're going to be deducting
2 hours from that total time.
Ready to find out what
you're building at home?
- Let's do it.
Chris, you're up first.
All right.
Oh-- all right.
Chris, you landed on the pandat.
How are you feeling?
I'll keep it.
I don't want to get that thing.
[laughter]
Fair enough.
NARRATOR: The pandat
is a two-handed war
sword native to the Dayaks
of Borneo in Indonesia.
Exclusively used in
combat, the weapon's
single-edged blade
was uniquely angled
and featured a wide, flat tip.
The ornate design made it a
very effective lethal weapon,
delivering devastating
chops through the armor
of an opponent.
This fierce sword was
featured in season three
of "Forged in Fire," where
the smiths both turned
in beautiful weapons.
But ultimately, the better
balanced blade won the title.
Damond, you ready?
Let's go.
The kelewang.
So of course, I
get the kelewang.
I don't have a quench tank that
would fit something like that.
The odds of it landing
on kelewang again
are not too high, so
I'm willing to bet
to get one of the other two.
Hit me again.
- All right.
That means we're
going to be taking
2 hours off your 35 hours.
You will have 33 hours to
build whatever I land on.
The boa-zande.
You happy with it?
Oh, yeah.
NARRATOR: The boa-zande sword
is a Central African weapon that
features a long pierced ricasso
and a wide-leaf shaped blade
that tapers to a
steep, sharp tip.
The razor-sharp
edges were designed
to deliver devastating stabs
and slashes into an enemy.
The boa-zande was previously
seen in season seven of "Forged
in Fire," where, while both
smiths faced challenges
achieving the width
of this weapon,
victory went to the lighter,
more comfortable sword.
All right, Chris,
you're going to have
35 hours to build your pandat.
Damond, you've got 33 hours
to build your boa-zande.
And gentlemen, don't forget,
these are high stakes.
The house is putting
up $10,000 in the title
of "Forged in Fire"
champion for the winner.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, man.
Good.
My name is Chris Gardner.
I am 37 years old,
from Las Vegas, Nevada.
I'm doing a sword
with 327 layer billet.
Looks like I have enough steel.
I'm pretty happy
with how it's going.
It's looking pretty good so far.
Something goes wrong
with the quench,
I could basically
destroy my blade.
Planning for the worst,
hoping for the best.
All right, here we go.
I get it over to
the quench tank,
and it comes out straight.
That's good.
Hard.
This blade is a little awkward.
It's a weird shape I need a
specific edge on this thing
that's going to hold
up during these tests
and still stay sharp.
Damond, he's an excellent smith.
Can't wait to see what
he brings, but you know,
I hope mine's just
a little bit better.
My name is Damond Clark.
I am 45 years old.
Started doing Brazilian
Jujitsu about 12 years ago,
so I think that part of the
reason I'm a pretty decent
blacksmith is the
discipline and the strength
it takes to be in jujitsu.
It's looking good so far.
I'm going to draw out the
basic blade shape for now.
I gotta worry about
getting parameter lengths.
We'll just see how things go.
So 243 layers, that's
what I was shooting for.
I really like the
look of bronze,
so I'm going to put a
bronze guard and pommel.
So I've got my pommel
tapped, and now I
need to thread my tank.
Shoot, I don't think
this is going to work.
I see that the
threads are not right.
With the threads as
shallow as they are,
it's not going to
grab the pommel,
and it's not going to be tight.
I build the new pommel,
I get it on the handle.
Everything looks
good, it's tight.
That's going to work just fine.
Now I'm ready to
start moving forward.
It looks great.
The pattern is really
showing really well.
So now it's time to get
the final edge on it,
and get this sucker sharp.
Losing two hours didn't really
change my plan of action.
She's a winner.
I feel really good
about what I made.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
I'm going to take your weapon
and deliver some lethal strikes
on this big carcass.
Because these are two
different kinds of weapons
with different designs,
they may cut differently
or perform differently.
But overall, the feeling
and the way I wield them
should be the same.
Chris, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah, let's do it.
[slashing]
[chuckling]
All right, Chris, let's
talk about your pandat here.
When I picked it up,
it felt so light.
A little forward heavy, but
that's what it's supposed
to be, because it's a chopper.
Your handle
construction is smooth.
I can fit both hands perfectly.
There's no extra space.
Overall, sir, with the function
of a chopper like this,
it will kill.
Thank you.
Damond, you're up next.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
[slashing]
Yeah.
All right, Damond, let's
talk about your boa-zande here.
Your handle construction
fits my hand perfectly.
I like the palm swell there,
because it locks my hand in.
Your edges are sharp.
They cut deeply and thrust
nicely through this carcass.
Overall sir, your boa-zande--
it will kill.
Yeah!
Welcome to our strength test--
the porcelain pot chop.
It's going to be a lot of fun
to see what your blades do
to the pots, but
I'm more concerned
about what the pots do to
your blades and their edges.
And Chris, you're up first.
You ready to go?
Yeah.
I'll take it.
[music playing]
Chris, you survived.
Good job.
You've got a little
bit of glinting,
and you got a couple
of slight rolls,
but they're very minimal.
Everything's still
straight, sharp, sturdy.
Good job.
Thank you.
Damond, you ready to go?
Can we just talk this out?
No.
[music playing]
Damond, you survived.
Good job.
Some minor glinting, a
couple low rolls on the edge,
but I mean, still, overall,
a very sharp blade.
Nice job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness
test, the vine slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm going to take your weapon
and slash through these vines.
Chris, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
All right.
[music playing]
All right, Chris, let's
talk about your pandat here.
Your edges easily cut
through the vines, sir.
Overall, your
pandat, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Damond,
the final gamble.
Are you ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Damond.
The edges are sharp and cut
cleanly through the vines.
Your weapon, too,
sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
Well, well, well.
Both of your weapons performed
extremely well in all three
of our tests.
But in this competition, we have
to have a winner, which means
one of you has to go home.
And the winner of today's
"Forged in Fire" competition
is--
Chris.
Congratulations.
Now, Damond, unfortunately, your
blade just didn't make the cut,
and Jay is going
to tell you why.
Damond, you've got everything
in the world to be proud of.
They tested equally.
Fit and finish in
the finer details
is what it came down to,
and Chris just squeaked
a little bit ahead of you.
That's it.
Cool.
Damond, up against any other
blade, it would have won.
But unfortunately, you did not
come out with the win today.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the Forged floor, man.
Thanks for having me, guys.
Good job, buddy.
I know that with what they
told me about my weapon,
that there really
wasn't a loser here.
I'm taking home just a
fantastic experience.
This competition is amazing.
I am humbled by this.
It's been wonderful.
Chris, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and you're going to be taking
home a check for $10,000, man.
Congratulations.
Aw, thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
I'm, like, in disbelief.
This title of "Forged in Fire"
champion means a lot to me.
It's something that I
can always take with me.
I am the "Forged
in Fire" champion!
[music playing]